foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh
I am kind of present and I'm kind of not
present
still waking up
[Music]
waiting for King to get on
[Music]
hmm
hmm
[Music]
I played more of a Pokemon yesterday
Dawn
put a little bit more
just seeing what's up
[Music]
[Music]
all right
let's do it
King should be on here momentarily
my name's Peter my friends call me Pete
foreign
[Music]
let's adjust this a little bit
so I did do a little bit of research
when it comes to this game
[Music]
okay
it's a lot of ladybugs in this area all
of a sudden
where is King
what's the game you guys want to see us
play
hey
curious on that what's the game you guys
want to see us play
okay
I think I still have that wrestling game
downloaded
no I don't I installed it
absolutely not I'm not playing that
I'm making a statement for Halo I I
don't believe we should reward
games that function half the time
you know when I decided to really like
draw a line with Halo is when we were
trying to play
Community day and it was just so glitchy
now once I figure out how Forge you know
obviously we got to play for like
Community Days and stuff and there's not
a whole lot I can do about that and I'm
not even saying Halo is like a bad game
I just feel like
you know there's a lot of stuff that hey
FID really can't go into
because I promise you I'll keep my mouth
shut but
just it's a shame how that happened
how did you
you know what I think we should play
this game
I think you guys would enjoy this game
actually
you know we could play Battleship
mean King playing Battleship he might
cheat though he might stream snipe me I
could see King doing that he might
stream snipe me
I this human fall flight is a fun game
to play with multiple people
tag King on Twitter and tell him I'm
waiting
oh King's on his way home
[Music]
uh
I mean sure you could come in here
that's fine
this is a community stream
[Music]
might play something else while we wait
for King King will be here in like 15-20
minutes
play some fall guys I've been trying I
don't know uh slow-mo you want to play
fortnite
do you want to play fortnite slow-mo
fortnite
I'm down to try I'm down to play slow mo
all right let me
so what do you mean like a few do you
mean like literally a few minutes or
like a few hours
you have to be a little bit more
specific on what you mean by that
yeah I I definitely interested in doing
Forge stuff
I just got to really figure out how to
like use the forged map you know maybe
maybe that's what we'll do we'll after
this game we'll go into the forge thing
and test around
oh you playing Road company that game
still exists
the game still exists
and I'm not saying it's a bad game or
anything
people that's coming in
um
we still kind of unsure what we're gonna
play
I think I'm gonna try to lean towards
fortnite because uh
I just wanna I I just want to level up
that pass because I haven't leveled it
up I don't think I bought the season
pass yet but with those battle passes
you could get to the moment you leveled
them up
okay take forever
that was just going
normally I'm one of the first people in
there
am I doing squads
I guess I am
huh
nah the only disrespectful thing is you
playing that game
no I'm joking if you want to play that
then it is what it is man
foreign
I get it
sometimes people like punishing
themselves
um my gamer tag is
uh Lord addict four two seven eight let
me see if
because I kind of want to change it to
Lord addict IOP
see if that's available
I guess it's not
oh you're gonna address my slander
you're gonna come in here and try to
bully me into thinking the game's good
I see you
typical slo-mo
try to bully your way into everything
you know God is so
you know I got a soul I like that name
actually
um
okay uh I'll look in a second I put
myself on a do not disturb
I won't be looking at the chat while I
do this
because you get eliminated for this
oh my God
get up
oh we got a jump
we're waiting
go go go go go go
mushroom head man
I'm so dead
oh my God I hate that
there you go Donald Tucker
uh
uh probably not
I might play Pokemon later on today
probably on the twitch Channel though
it won't be on the um
on the YouTube channel I don't know you
probably gonna play fortnite with
slow-mo and King
I wasn't gonna play grounded but I feel
like I'd enjoyed fortnite more
oh look at that
slow-mo scared he's scared to come up on
here
see I told you guys he'd be all talk
I told you guys
come on man
you need to beat those two
all right so we're still moving on
foreign
what's going on Kev
you play Pokemon what exactly is
what is the co-op
Dawn
like is it just like walking around with
someone
this is probably a wrap right here I'm
not gonna lie
what's up
brandator brandator uh probably
butchered your name it's okay though
you guys know what's up
three
foreign
come on man thank you
one two three
come on get
all right we got straight up to the last
one
foreign
three
three on that side
okay okay we almost got this
foreign
yet so we're good so far
come on hurry up guys okay team
qualified okay we're good we're good
we're good
yeah I'm waiting for King right now or
SJ he should be here soon uh I don't
know what we're gonna play yet you know
right now let me go ahead and uh
erase that
this is kind of like a as far of the
moment last thing that's why there's no
thumbnail
foreign
I don't know
I just
I'm not really feeling the way Halo's
been working on Community Day I'm gonna
be real with you guys
yeah maybe maybe that fixed some of the
issues
what kind of modes do they have
yeah I don't I don't play any of those
games in uh in 30 frames
I'm playing Pokemon in 30 frames and
feel like I'm gonna throw up
it's rough man
reading the chat right now
I think it's a good thing that we could
pop in is um
we could do
I know there's a couple things we can do
uh there's a
you got banned last night
yeah Pokemon definitely looking rough
no one's denying that
it's a shame too because when I play of
it you know I honestly feel like it it's
evolving the
the playlist of Pokemon
but unfortunately
they haven't you know
you can't you can innervate all you want
but if you can't
have the game Run properly
it's kind of pointless at that point
oh no
this one's kind of rough
uh
they try to grab you here man
don't trust these people
they'll try to grab you in a heartbeat
foreign
used to just jumping these because to me
if you don't jump them you get used to
not jumping them and then you'll get hit
that one time
that's an Among Us character
no I'm gonna
foreign
this is a cute game I see you
I like to get on this right side like
the moment it starts
try to eliminate people
all right we all made up at one so we're
good
pinnamon is awful no Gameplay at all
yeah I wasn't playing Pokemon that time
my girlfriend took oh you talking about
yeah I've been done wrong twice
recently I was done wrong with Wise Old
game you're posted an old picture that
my girlfriend took with her little
cattier headphones on and I was hit with
that but it is what it is you guys are
just having fun as long as it's not
disrespectful I don't care
what's the point of having a community
if you guys can't clown on me
occasionally
I hate these penguins stuff
I'm gonna lose this penguin one
we're the red team
get it get it no that's my dude
stop him
stop that blue bastard
no
I got it
blue don't even have one point
it's red or nothing man right or nothing
oh look at Orange trying to be cute
you doing Orange
can't do nothing Orange
me and orange just go side by side
get it get it
come here
man it's kind of ridiculous like how bad
we're treating this red team look at
Blue here you go Blue there you go
no give it to him
here blue
take it
take it grab it
grab it
see there's an update on
Kings uh almost here
I just don't like the way YouTube makes
us look I feel like
I feel like it it's bad that's why part
of me wants to do these streams on
Twitch
because twitch make like the the actual
view of twitch looks really good
played right after finishing plague
Tower equipment no real gameplay either
yeah
I feel you guys
pen was just not the type of game for me
Cog seemed to like it
um I don't know yet I don't know if I
want to stream on the IOP twitch or my
twitch
get the basketball
oh
that's how you score
get these gains
ah
go go
oh
how is yellow scoring so much
we need some people on offense man
go go go go go go go
oh
get it
oh they got it
go go go go
yes
that's how you win a game folks
see that when I just did there that w
first game it was on squad though
I I beat this Falls
I liked it it was a good game
I tried um Forge
it wasn't working out so well for me man
Forge is really complicated this year
foreign
foreign
I would play Pokemon until King gets
here but
I can't
so what we're gonna do
is we're going to play on the void
I don't like warzone
look I don't know if we're gonna be
playing Halo long but we'll play
uh
all right so
this is Forge
can you go faster
yeah all right that's a little too fast
Forge is is like really complicated
ought to like really sit here and learn
how to do stuff
what's up King
can you hear me
can you hear me oh
all right you should be able to hear me
now
what are we on right now uh
I don't know what do you want to play
you wanna
yeah we'll play some fortnite
all right
I need to get that level up a little bit
yeah yeah yeah
um did it did you uh get anywhere what I
left you that day
um not really
I don't know why levels pardon me don't
like playing fortnite but uh like alone
I don't know why
okay
no problem
I'm gonna mute my phone
just been a real active day yeah
that's why when I'm looking I'm like let
me uh tweet this out I'm like oh my God
babe he's on right now yeah well I said
uh I'll be ready at 11 and you didn't
say nothing so I just figured you'd be
ready at 11.
and I thought in the chat that I had put
um 12 o'clock
and
I looked and I was like no you didn't
buddy I'm
still very upset I didn't get my hands
on that uh on the
the uh Naruto skins
why they got them why the monkeys gotta
be girls man I would have loved that
brought a monkey
uh let me see here
the zero builds Duos
oh look at this she can turn into a
whole cat
or is that a mouse it's a mouse you can
turn into an old mouse all right hashtag
stop snitching no rats oh my God
gotta take it seriously it can be out
here wearing a whole rat skin
foreign
let me grab it
oh see look at you
yo addict let's go baby
oh hold on hold on hold on hold on I
don't like this
it's ready up just ready up there we
don't need all all this extra stuff all
right hold up
oh it's a Naruto Hokage
oh there's saying gun too
yes sir
got ready up gotta get it
[Music]
hold on
let's go
[Music]
you're killing me man you finished the
ball barrier right uh it is it's the
movie about the uh
the
what do they call those things the
Airbnb yeah Airbnb yeah I I I I I have
the majority of it watched I had to go
through our stuff last night it'll be
watching no problem
yep yep yep very creepy stuff very cute
you know just some some uh quick bars
but uh you know what I was done with
that movie
when she came out out of the bathroom
and he had the wine glasses and the wine
I was like this dude's clearly not
reading clear signs you know what I'm
saying yeah you don't know how to read
the room properly
where we go
all right hold on let me find a place on
the minute that
um what quest I had we had the high
octane Quest we got some daily drink got
some weekly
what I gotta do Airborne locations right
track that so we can go here
foreign
I'm definitely short
where you at
salomo's scared of the conversation by
Road company so he left
oh man you know damn well he's supposed
to be in on this Fortnight here man
you did so good together
foreign
foreign
yeah well it's perfect for hitting
people
we got people coming
oh
right below us
okay I'm gonna set up here
foreign
they're down there with you
it's him it's him
they're directly below me
I'm acting up I'm walking inside
everybody
here they go
he's up here with me
oh he's got a shotgun
it's two of them yeah I see him
foreign man
watch out shock of the deadly boy
it's the boys
check out the whole team come over here
hold on
they had plenty of stuff they took all
the good stuff here
yeah we got it back in gold
[Music]
Cobra I don't need none of that stuff
I cut the floor out when he was shooting
you I cut the floor out beneath them
that's what I was trying to be that's
why I was trying to like run around a
lot so he couldn't
I wanted I wanted you to be a surprise
you know what I'm saying I'm definitely
getting this crap hey uh you're gonna
need this
that spray so you don't have to carry
bandages with
close to the circle anywhere
I'm just uh killing people over here
because I gotta bouncing for it
stop stop stop
what
I could have swore I heard me what
doesn't matter I didn't see any movement
there's a key someplace yeah and there's
a
right here
there you go found it got it
here's a what I got it a lock box
there's another Mist here
I got one
I always try to be in the Mystic things
oh they working out in the gym I've
never been in here with them hold on
what's up y'all
cover DLR I don't need that
oh
everybody needs a damn off no I got I
got one
I got a blue
you should have a DMR yeah I dropped it
I dropped a green one up off the second
floor
well I got a green one right now
that's fine
let me see I keep hearing things you
know you had the people that's in the
room doing jump rope
that's stupid yeah
that's what the king wants I think
that's the king likes ah
one of these people ended up being a
real person
nope
you're looking at him as soon as you
gonna Flex on
I'm just gonna one decides he gonna he
gonna do extra stuff
oh let me get rid of this stupid thing
yes sir
what should my quality showing up bro
what
get another catch up just to hit another
catch up and stuff you see it
what are we looking for
guys ready
that's a boom sniper
why
one key you needed one key for both of
y'all come on the
the Western call is coming
we gotta go right now
I guess we're falling
it's pretty cool he's right there anyway
no
no
I'm gonna die
get the hell out of this what happened
were you being shot at
no I I got launched back
how did you guys
because I jumped on the super launching
pad thinking that it was going to Spring
me forward
Flyers got fired over here
oh blue damn off you best believe it
that's fired over here
over there oh okay over there yes sir
I'm gonna try to stay on the second
floor
don't you love how fortnite has slowly
jacked all the stuff that everyone else
made before that
oh that's what they do
I respect it though
yep and they're making their own
so I don't got no problem with
oh car over here
where you shoot
[ __ ] knock that dude oh
my bad for cursing where where are you
shooting at
oh where I put my marker I told you it
was people over there
come on jump in the car with me
all right let's see here
so I let that car up so they couldn't
have got too difficult they're driving
and smoking
he's right there
yeah
dropped his ass
on God I'm going in for the kid hold on
there's there's two boys up there
no no there's boys up there he's
shooting at his boy I'm gonna go kill
his mansion
he's running
he's going to the top floor
oh
he took the balloon
no but the
there's someone else coming
are you at
it's down he's he's below he's floating
he's running he's running at it keep
running
keep running keep running he running
he's in the blue get that launch pad
there you go
there you go he flew in the sky
he's right here he's right here he's
right here he's on her
hit it with a head shot he's up on top
of his mouth
Shield's gone
thank you he's behind that
I'm on him
there's his teammates over there it
looks like
he dropped me
this dude is right in front of me
he's right there I know I see him
I'm backing up up here
come this way those are two different
teams
they dropped me right here
hit me
it's a dude right here is your left
you're right
pick me up
come on come on come on
come on
we gotta we got it we got it we got it
we got it we got it we got it
we got it
there's a there's a shield thing out
here
she okay yeah sure okay no it's not a
keg it's just a a full show
all right hold on
oh [ __ ]
it's right there go
keep going just go let's go I'm gonna
make it
there's a car oh [ __ ]
what
oh my God
watch out there's two people over there
they're up here with me
you fighting them there's nothing I
could do right now
watch it you got to do that to sniper as
well
I got one
foreign
let's go baby let's go
they thought I was alone
get that spray get that spray right
there
I have no Shields yeah I I don't have
any either
whoa
oh move move
I can't believe you started shooting man
I knocked the other dude I had you I'm
sorry I'm I'm gonna jump in on the ad on
here
trying to eliminate the teams there's
only it's only uh four more people and
if we could take those guys out we can
take them out early do so
oh there's a shield there
that's what I'm grabbing
these are fighting up here let's go
let's insert ourselves
oh I'm being shot at yeah
over here over here
I'm on the midx I'm on a midx
stand up let's go Eddie
get that dance off
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why would you like you know what's
messed up they gotta Watch Me dance
[Laughter]
look let's see people in the chat not
actually playing fortnite not Halo
if you don't like the game man just come
next time we play another game like
yo we're gonna get to that the only
problem is
yo do we got anybody that wanted to join
us
foreign
[Music]
I got to get this one dance that I've
been looking for
all right
um
this air area is good
let me check my quest
I need one more person to kill over
there
me and addict was smoking people baby
oh thanks oh you're watching us oh okay
cool thank you appreciate it did I
support
if your lady ain't supporting you then
you need to go away she needs to go she
needs to go anybody that can hear me
that's your lady or your man don't
support what you do they need to go
no if and the butt about it
if she don't somebody else will
oh King is spicy today
I gotta watch him to call it I gotta um
let me know
I'm still in the air
okay I was turning uh yeah he's gonna
join join us
the kamehameh waves no longer in the
game
nope
that was a bust
thing too
that's how
that's how you properly
um
introduce other characters to your game
attic where are you I got a repair kit
looking for
I got a um shell cake I want to throw it
down but you're not next to me I am
coming
let me get the shotgun real quick
okay someone decided
you notice how they necessary right
all right throw it down
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right so we got Shield
s fully shielded up
a shield bubble did they just take the
the bubble from yeah
yes they did
okay
hello
what
I'm gonna burn you
I'mma burn you what do you call it
you're ridiculous that's the picture
thing
we got people shooting over here oh
that's you
okay we got them on the other side
oh you guys definitely want we're gonna
want to be
watching IOP tomorrow for our uh Game of
the Year Crown your lord segment
yep
because I posted we're supposed to be
playing grounded so you know people join
in looking for grounding
and did you do any more on that grounded
that um the one that we was on okay good
I think I got some resources but that's
all
where is ah here it is I got to get my
gun all right legendary shotgun I want
this
if you got a key you open these chests
over here man
[Music]
what you got
uh
oh I need to do something
I don't have a key so I can't use that
how do I do this split man
I don't know how to do that damn flip
Somebody went up that was you yeah that
was me
oh girl
I'm just I gotta feeling this area
the guys are around us we're just not
coming to this Airborne area
I'm looking
try to find out where we're going next
we're going to address the chat here in
a minute man we're gonna dress the
channel oh no they they just bickering
about fortnight
Halo rules he just doesn't like fortnite
he says it's a pubg okay copy it is but
they did they did pubg better than pubg
this is true
yeah
Yeahs is definitely in fortnite man uh
and and King is Naruto
yes I am sir
the whole cocky bird
oh yes
the attic didn't get a chance to do that
let me do that
oh I hear something
that was me uh okay that was all secro
was terrible I'm lucky I was skeptical
about it and waited for the 20 price
that girl was a great game it is our
game of the year sex yeah secretary is
crazy so if you good you know you could
play the game but uh I actually feel
like sakro in a lot of ways is better
than elderly
well in in its execution I guess but for
me it was not uh it was not that
but I'm pretty sure that they looked at
secular and said yo how can we
uh take this formula oh Sacramento a lot
some Dark Souls people don't like Sakura
because it changes the formula it's all
about pairing
oh does that you did you just get on top
of something yeah that was me that was
me okay
I'm coming here to open up this chest
because I got a key and there's a chest
over here with a gun left I want
I want a shot down here
legendary snap out
scaring the living [ __ ] number one shut
up don't worry about it oh okay so we
got people over there I don't see him
I'm gonna show you
they over this way
right there look let them close in a
little bit
I don't think they see us yet
no they don't see it
I don't have a DMR either if I had a DMR
I can just really break they're right
under they're about to be right under me
I'm gonna start fired
[ __ ] no somebody was up here somebody
was up here somebody just went down to
them
man I can't shoot him to save my life
we got another dude that's below us
yeah I I see him
I missed like every shot
one
knocked one
all right
knock the other you killed both of them
all right it's another dude under you
American
thank you
he's on the platform with you I stepped
on something and it shot me across the
room
so I'm with where you got where you were
shooting those guys
he's under you
I'm looking for him
he's here he's been sneaky
I'm going to the oh no I just broke both
my legs
could have been worse
all right we got to get out of here
attic jump on the platform fly out
fly out
all right good he's flying
oh
see anybody no
yeah there's that dude there okay dude
that was running from us what up mate we
are streaming we streaming right now
but um
all right everything's good bro
how's the baby there's a car right there
okay
you didn't have to look I'm coming just
tell them you're straight yeah
I don't know I gotta hit him
all right you said it was two people
with uh one is behind us and there's a
car in front of us
I'm gonna kill that guy
you want to just wait for him
yeah he got to show up he he got to
watch out for the other people
he didn't go in the air
he should be this way probably
oh
that's me that's me brother man don't do
that to me
there you go found him over here
this is how we hide in plain sight
all right just just pop shot them I'm
coming around
foreign
we picked a fight we shouldn't have
picked
now there's more dudes over here
these do that golden snipers and [ __ ]
watches
let's get them all
we're in between stuff at it
I had to get over
here
watch it we got snipers and everything
he's up there
trying to try to get you off
I told you we should have went there
fine you're right you're right
let me eat this food real quick you
wanna play solo matching real quick
while I eat I'll I'll talk to the chat
okay cool oh you want to load up
um
grounded
yeah we'll play ground we'll go to
grinder
all right let me um let me switch over
to ground it while we doing that
ah okay guys
so we can actually do it like we said
we're gonna do uh we can change our
minds I ain't worried about this
I worry about them all the time
all right
so what you what you guys want to talk
about man I see you guys in there are
you very talkative until I ask what you
want to talk about that you guys are
completely
nowhere to be found
all right I see Dodd saying I won't be
in
it won't be a game by for at least a
year I don't know what that is
someone explained to me what what you
guys talking about there he's probably
talking he's probably talking about
stray astray
I'm gonna have a very interesting
conversation tomorrow about Good Old
stray
oh I I I'm I'm a I'm a flame straight
too
don't get it twister I'm flaming that
thing too
it's going down
what you right I'm gonna be upset if it
Wins Game of the Year part of me wants
it to win game of the year just because
I feel like people are gonna have a
meltdown if it wins game of the year but
then the other part of me is like it
shouldn't win game of the year it
doesn't need to be there
what are you talking about strike yeah
because uh you know at the end of the
day like
the these game of the years
it's other people's opinions it's not
yours
you I think you could I think you can
question
if
something
if something has any form of like
credibility
because I don't think at this point the
credibility of that's pretty much gone
oh
yeah that's the only reason I even talk
about it is because we uh
we we do stuff like that on the show
no no we don't hear you
we don't hear you eating
I'm gonna probably have some today I
don't know
another peanut butter jellies
right now King is eating that that's
what's going on
all right
I'm
going in right now
I don't want to talk who said he wanted
to you could still jump on if you want
though
yeah but ain't nobody want to play
fortnite in this thing
[Music]
yeah I've been there now
IOP
it doesn't matter
there is a laboratory
under the the lake
huh
that's
yeah there's there's a raven been there
I wonder if I could stab it
I'm going I'm going for that I'm going
for that bird
oh I can't reach you
yeah there's definitely spiders
underwater
all right hold on
well geez you messed up man oh
I hear you guys let me fix that
what happened I put my uh I turned off
the gameplay while you was eating
forgot to turn it back on
yeah there you guys go
shout out to the 50 people in here man
oh hit that like button
what's the next thing they wanted us to
do in the story
oh we have to find the Hedge lab
I'm trying to heal myself
I'm behind over here messing around with
that dirty water
I'm trying to get to that what you call
it
get over here
that's fine you can join on your
smartphone it's okay
man you got a lot of Smurf accounts done
got one on Twitter one on Xbox
done tell them yo stop snitching bee
had a guy here with the ratatouilles
I mean he writing himself out
oh look at tadpole I gotta kill it
I gotta get up on it
oh that scared me
these spiders are coming up a lot
further than they used to
yo kill the Deadpool
what is this
a water Batman
a bot fly
I'm gonna go and see if this weapon is
where it's supposed to be
I'm gonna go
check out this bird
I don't think you can fight this bird
um buddy
sorry to break the news to you
I found a whole
situation yeah we've been here before
I haven't yeah
let's see what I can and oh I got
slides
this place is in power though it doesn't
look like
analyze
it's IOP Don
oh I got brain power unlocked so what I
want to unlock
holy snaps
torch upgrade
Yeah question though
we got to craft a gas mask
oh what's that up there
what is that a little energy joint
that's up there
you have to go to the forest up north
okay
um
let's go ahead and go to sleep because
it's about to turn dark
all right well we got to bed that
remember it's over here
when we woke up from
better hurry up so spider don't get you
though
I ain't afraid no books
I'm in the water
you will come in the water
are there all this bubbling around me in
the water
[Music]
face God
joined us only to go to bed quite a
stick down go to sleep yeah we totally
needs you sleep dog
what's lit
I don't know where he spawned maybe at
the old base
laughs
he went to the old block
Don is an old block
he's by the basketball
it's too much I don't know anything
I'm blind
we might have to go to him
a monkey sounding
oh snap
I think it's ridiculous
okay so we sleeping
uh yeah I can't be the only one feeling
tired
time to hit the hay
[Music]
what the hell is going on over there
I'm gonna go find Dawn
we see him
where's go around
there's a bunch of spiders in this area
I ain't trying to fight these spiders
ah
man I had that weave right in my sights
you didn't have nothing to
me got it
there you go
foreign
Jews you're drinking juice
that punch
look at this sun rays coming through
beautiful
morning bro
I feel so happy
oh ladybug
I'ma hang out with the ladybug try to
get a tight a spider to antagonize I
don't even need to boil it
and make a spider get his head pinched
off
what's up spiders
I'm right here next to the ladybug baby
oh
spider right here
a little one We're not gonna be able to
fight that thing
the little one no because the big one
comes out
yeah I got ladybug over here
get him better than starving I think
I'm not picky
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm coming at it
[Music]
it's about to kill me
you better fight him
[Music]
right there
if he hits me one more time it's a wrap
all right
[Music]
I told you I was gonna come back from
the dead cut off your head
more poison
I see things a little funky in the world
[Music]
there go my book bag baby
yeah I don't think that um
that spider's not coming back anytime
soon
that's right
go about your business fighter but I
need about your being I need something
for my health
what is Dawn doing that's what I want to
know
we come back our original base is just
caught on fire everything's destroyed
don't die
you're like we shouldn't have trusted
him why did we trust him
I'm over here with this ladybug
but I'm gonna use this ladybug to fight
this fighter
[Music]
I could have swore I've been picking up
stuff for this
cook
oh no
oh no
I'm cutting this fat away find a
spiderweight
s it's it's you you're hopeless it's
over for you
yeah you can join the party Don
yeah Don come on get in here
help
I got ate by land mites we need four
people man
back baby hammer and him who's the man
foreign
[Music]
people
I gotta invite him
left bumper
oh look at that tree
but you know what game I'm addicted to
hmm
some of them
somerville's good
it's
yes one hour baby that's it it's not one
hour yet
it's one o'clock is when I'm done
what time is it it's one o'clock now
30 minutes okay let's see I got I got 30
minutes from now
is this done
ah this one here boy she's a special
Beast
taking a look wearing my book bag thank
you that was delicious baby
[Music]
there we go I needed that Health man
I guess it
couldn't hear him
[Music]
yo this land that I'm in right now is
nothing but mites
have you ever been over here uh-huh
did you go on the other side of the
the wooden wall
oh
snap for me yeah
coming here with the spider bee
I don't even know why you went over
there
because I was beating up the mic hey
does the chat dude do we want to observe
King get killed by a spider
dude I'm busting these mics now
oh it's a stink bug
s
there's a stink bug around here
somewhere
I think you smell it
crazy
let me go over here
I wish they would have they came out
with that apparatus that they were
talking about with um
the The Joint from the South Park game
where you could put the smell on your
face and then it'll it'll emit different
smells
then we try that at a pack
remember
[Music]
here's Dawn
you made it yeah
he's getting closer to us
hello Dawn
Dawn's running from me
I don't I'm not feeling this energy
the gun is running he's running from me
wow stop
running from it
I would say wait till you see our base
but he's watched the stream so he's
definitely gonna know what our base
looks like
I'm not picky
I gotta make stuff
my inventory is full
I got all the shells I can carry
over here is the bass dog
I feel safe on out in this water
that's all that matters all right so I
made that
a pebble spear oh that's the wax sphere
right
um
Acorn shovel I need crew rope make a
acorn shovel oh a bow
evil Shields
okay here we go eyepatch a might helmet
I need grub hot I need to find more
grubs
Acorn face masks is it better than what
I got
we're even to a gas mask stick ah
the pure level of Jesus that you're able
to concoct
oh
I'm sorry
a juices to be made I need to make some
cool rope
all right
did I we need an acorn shovel right
to dig up grubs I need grubs
you got slime torch mode we can grab
all right so
I made this shovel the words
I gotta cook some meat oh
I'm gonna get some acorns
we need more eggs look what I got
roasted on the fire baby
yes
[Music]
I was killing I carried all I could
carry
foreign
right here
oh cool looking [ __ ] baby
I got food over here for us
anybody it's gonna burn up I gotta take
it off
breaking this sap
still
look at all these mushrooms look at all
these chickens
hey look I I apologize uh Dawn's like if
one of our base saying this isn't a base
you snap
you're snapping on our base dog yeah
yeah we don't there's friendly damage
don't think we won't we won't retaliate
yeah
listen man I invite you to my home and
you tell me my home doesn't fit your
hands he
he didn't he didn't wipe his feet off
when he came in the door he just sat
right down muddy feet everything King
oh man done done we are part of a team
and in this team
oh what how you feel about our base now
Dawn
[Music]
yeah
hmm
I have nothing to analyze uh
uh yeah that nose to yourself
who killed two wings
it's probably Dawn
Dawn's so good at this game I expect to
see a spider being killed
what happened to that spider Dawn
I'm gonna need I'm gonna need you to to
show up
not just a little bit a lot
oh
what happened at it
the spider bit me
a little one or a big one it was a big
one
oh man I got out I got away though
oh my God I don't I don't think my blood
pressure can handle much more of that
that's scary that scared me man
was a little bit different
all that spider's on him
y'all look crazy far from me
allow me to reintroduce myself go Dog go
run run don't run
you just came across a big spider and a
little spider
don't bring that nonsense over here Dom
bring me no bad news done
we don't want to see no spiders
there's some wasps around here too
and a bee
spiders bad
there's a spider over there Dom watch
out
foreign
number ladybugs over here baby
I got quartz
come up here man if I got courts man
how did Dom get away from that spider
it Dawns the man be
um
oh okay so the spider's over here
next to um
I'm Gonna Make Them Fight the uh
the what's we call the ladybugs
I'm running
how you make them fight the ladybugs you
have to uh
to like get around the ladybug he has to
hit the ladybug once
that's way to go I saw him
there is a spider around there I just
don't know where
yeah I saw him
I'm standing right next to the ladybug
oh they're going to fight us I see him
hey put on the move
you have to get like the ladybug and the
spider around each other
so one will accidentally hit the other
don't be surprised if that spider wins
that fight though
there's a bunch of ladybugs over there
oh God
I'm gonna make that spider get jumped
Calvin someone uh Galvin joined
that's Galveston yeah
galaxies you can join our party
come on hit him hit the ladybug
why won't you hit the ladybug
push you in the water
[Music]
oh
I'm right here with you I'm down for all
that smoke too
you ever seen you can join the party or
not he's joined just joined on Monday
okay you can talk you can talk brother
it goes without saying but that is a big
spider
he plays this all the time
that spider one
fighting with nothing he's still
fighting let's go
same time
I don't want you turning around hitting
me
we need to help the ladybug no we don't
that ladybug is over
look at you
why are you hitting the ladybug
because I was Trapped In The West
we ain't I ain't helping them they the
ladybug can fend for herself
well it's a he and I don't think so yeah
yeah got this ladybug
this
get another ladybug over here
oh the spider died yeah
and Crossing
all right let me get over here and see
what's that oh wow that was weird
um where's our base at it's this one
what
oh I walked really far away that's what
I did
yo yo how are you down there
yeah I'm not really comfortable down
here
spiders show up here
we shout out to my man lady bit though
that ladybug man
oh
that was it I got 10 I got 11 minutes
that ladybug is a walking w
that's right
a whole juggernaut
that I'm the Juggernaut itch
[Laughter]
y I thought he's gonna beat him
but it was like us ladybug was like
that's all you got
are you there for breakfast
you have to be a little bit stronger
comrade
you ain't spoiled me
what hey you ain't even spoil meat are
you nah
it'll look like
I said it you need some spoil me buddy
gonna drink some alcohol
foreign
I Wish It Would Rain on this guy
they haven't put that in I thought they
said he was gonna do that
I like to know where the water comes
from
well so we was up there to get weaved
out
oh where I gotta go I gotta go to the
thing to analyze it right
oh I can't remember
well there's some water
if I need to drink water I need to drink
nasty water
yes never drink nasty water
cleaner
I can't believe that
spider they had our number man
on his back
Parts no more man if you come back man I
know exactly who to go get hey Devo
yeah all I do is stand on top of his
back
that ladybug definitely did it
quite Authority was tough that ladybug
bites well I didn't even think about
that someone in the chat said the uh
that it would it would the raindrops
would kill you
oh whip your head boy
we are never killing that reason so you
can forget that
I try to throw something
yeah
oh
all right
so
wait a second somebody usually
okay we have to
craft uh Clover Hood
I hope this is enough to keep me safe
yeah we'll definitely uh
we'll definitely play redfall
oh for sure
if I'm playing God of War you know I'm
playing Red Bull stop it
I'm uh probably hit up Microsoft to give
us a couple codes so we can have some
content out when it comes out
yeah that'd be nice Trail marker
relocate
oh look at y'all trying to be fancy
I'm doing way too much
where are you what are you doing over
there
I'm doing way too much I don't know what
I'm doing to be honest with you but I
know damn well there's gonna be
something to get me murdered
I only got eight minutes
Saturday buddy no fights today can't
wait to Jake Paul Jake Paul's out there
doing stupid stuff making sure he starts
with everybody but Andrew Tate
my money's gonna take yeah I think I
think Tate's probably I don't know he
ain't really he he ain't fought in a
long time too so
Pete is a different type of animal
yeah I feel like Andrew's a little bit
more in his prime than the other people
Jake's fought too so yeah
I'll have to watch that one with you
it's gonna be fun
can't get back up on this rock
I hear a ladybug
yeah ladybug what up baby
there's a spider out here I'm gonna have
to stand on this ladybug and let him
snap your face
zombie
I'm on some stuff over here boy I don't
know what I'm doing I'm Walling up
I gotta go bear with me
where is he going
where's this ladybug going there's
probably a spider over here
this is Mike Land This is Where I got
all that
fuzzy Mike juice
thank you
I don't see a spider yet
I love my best life now man
what the hell is that
foreign
book
yeah yo every time I hear a ladybug I
Had No Fear of Myself
something's over here
I made a shovel so you think I should
use the shovel to dig up those Weevil
dudes
I'm looking around
foreign
there's a lot of water
oh there's water over there's a bunch of
water
looks like a shriveled up baby's head
oh you are maybe Mr Dickerson
I need help
I'm getting me killed
foreign
without you
Let Me In Coach oh yeah you guys are
lost you
it's hopeless for you guys
oh
45 there's like a billion lavas over
there I'm no longer interested yeah but
I got a whatchamacallit
we can kill them
yeah I'm almost dead
come on lover come on no
you guys can have all that
it might as well say Galveston was
knocked out trying to help King because
that's the real story over there
and it's time for me to go
get back to the base before you get off
okay
spawn a kid case
well it's kid case
you stay there I can give you your stuff
back
okay
a kid case yeah
how do you do that
did your book back open back there
yeah yeah the Game host could do that
your book bag is over here Galveston
yeah
anything yet
it's a whole spider
okay
King over there getting knocked out man
you sent me over you you set me up B I
didn't set you up you're the one that
did that you're the one that's
adventuring with nothing out in the
night
I got a big ass stick pulled have you
not have you not seen what what the dark
breeds out man
yeah I do want to understand what the
dog brings out again oh
look at that spider trying to get over
here
he gonna get you one day one thing I
think he's gonna glitch on that little
leaf and come over here
well I gotta go guys
it has been fantastic
y'all in good hands with attic
Galveston
have a good day
oh this is going to be a long day I got
a lot of work to do around the house
hate that stuff
catch you guys later man see ya
so what do you guys want to play now
hello
I'm up for anything really
what you want to play dog
you guys got me for about another 30
minutes and I'm calling it in
even gonna find something to snack on
real quick
yeah I didn't have any gear or anything
didn't go so well
spider
what a matching sir
we just have to figure out how to
monetize it
[Music]
be something particularly like getting a
different yard to start in or a
different environment somewhere as a DLC
or something
this game
I want them to let me go in the house
make sure the house is filthy and has
all the bugs and everything in it it'll
be getting interesting
find out what's in your what's in your
room
like bed bed bugs
foreign
in here go to Game Pass
and download human fall flat
like that for a long time yeah
do it Dawn
yeah we could actually uh tell the king
we could play uh if people want to
fortnite with a 16-party group
yeah
to do that
this game's fun
most people it's fun
Goat Simulator three come out yet
I don't think
[Music]
foreign
said it came out he has it on Steam
the first one was kind of weird
we find that
I think all of them is kind of weird
yeah
on the bottom I bought Gotham Knights on
the Black Friday sale gotta try that out
now
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right I got you man
song
send me another one too
this is
the show's crazy
this game is crazy
got you Don
I wonder why you're not connecting
would it be easier to join a Discord you
gotta you guys are on the IOP Discord
I don't think I'm
trying to join but I couldn't figure out
wouldn't let me or something
all right
there you guys go
join the Discord
I got it because you want it on the
party in the Xbox or has it work yeah we
can draw the party
do you have the join feature
yeah yeah I see yeah let's just go to
college nation go to that because I know
that no that's for everyone
hello
[Music]
[Music]
can you guys hear me
hello
all right let me leave and come back
sometimes the disc will be messing up a
little bit guys
hello
hello
yeah let me just join from the actual
Discord
foreign
I should be able to hear you now
can you hear me
laughs
[Laughter]
I didn't but I didn't let us fall
I'm sorry God I'm gonna let you fall
oh you're holding on to me
oh my God
I can hear you got one
yeah
can you hear me
can you hear me Galvin
can you hear me Galvin
uh
is this you do I have you
uh
yeah I can hear me
hold up you're really low let me
foreign
talk now
yeah I can hear you better now
Calvin you're in the game chat
since he can't hear us Dawn let's get
Galvin grabbing for one side I'll grab
from the other
pick him up
[Music]
all right
yeah I can hear you
we gotta take this off
grab me pull me all right we're good now
I don't know
all right see if you can get me up that
uh pick that up all the way
go down there and help him
oh
all right we need to get
this all the way up
all right
send me up
all right
let me see if I can make it to you
okay you ready to grab this
let me grab it from the bottom
okay I'm gonna jump
uh grab it
right here get on this
foreign
go up
did he leave
he he left us just chill in there
now this is where stuff gets a little
challenging
I wanted to get King and kog to play
this
yeah you got a point there
got to play games it's fun to stream
look at the ragdoll physics on this game
it's crazy
you fall properly you need
that seems horrible
uh
I think I need one of you one of yours
helps
it's not moving oh I got it I'm moving
it I'm moving it
oh I barely made that
oh
um
uh no I think those are just tutorials
yeah
or you can do what I do just pick them
up
I'm waiting for you guys
oh here we go
I think you have to
one second
you have to go on the other side
all right I'll put the weight over
climbing higher to get even higher you
need to jump before grabbing the edge
raise your hands running toward the
obstacle all right we go here we go
jump
I made it
oh hold up don't don't fall don't fall
don't fall
climbing higher to get even higher you
need to get close to me I'll grab you
raise your hands running towards
keep going keep going
oh
what happened to Dawn
hold up
all right
let me get let me get myself right
all right we have to go this way
just grab it even uh no you have to get
a little bit higher than that
it's okay
I'm coming
oh yeah let me try that
all right got one got the other no
hold up
I got to grab like the very edge
okay here we go here we go
oh
we're moving we're moving boys
hold up
ah
oh I got it I got the achievement
okay here we go
you gotta we gotta do that one at a time
get over here and counterbalance my
weight
well go ahead and jump because I can do
this without counterbalance just run up
there I'll counterbalance your way
hey Derek's X gaming
I see you now
you don't have to spam the chat Fame I
see
ah
grab my head
Greg
uh
what is going on
grab my head with the whole grab me with
your other hand
no me not
what's going on
[Music]
all right all right let me let me okay
hold up hold it grab him
okay okay let me grab him
now grab him
grabbing gas grab him
ah
oh don't don't move don't move don't
move
yeah hold on
oh
I got you
you always want to jump with your hands
above your head
it's easier to grab things
he's going off the map
I don't grab that to take it like a man
you are done with
it is that on Xbox
you are finished
ah
no I'm not
how did this happen
I could do this
I believe
okay hold up baby I can't do it
laughs
I didn't die
can't even have my back
I'm gonna get up
I'ma Do It
almost
no you can't fall
all right let's see if we can
sign our way up here why do you keep
dropping more
Goodbye cruel world
look
no I've played a lot of it though
hold this
don't hold me hold that
foreign
no more windows
no more windows
all right let me go grab that
all right do it
you have to go the other way
go keep going
uh
foreign
get on the on it
that I got you you're not going nowhere
let go of the edge I got you
well I could swing you if you let go
I just dropped you
I don't know let me
let me get up here
oh God
hold up
all we have to get to the other side
all right how about
foreign
this is what we're gonna do grab onto
this
man this is yeah I'm falling off now too
I'm about to grab the floor the moment I
get up yeah
see what this does
probably this
it broke
it broke
all right let's go
where did that open
oh open the door
can you hold it open
oh my God
it's probably easier one of you both
that you grab from each side
okay hold up
foreign
all right hold up there's a different
way we can do this
let's try to use these
to lever
it back
hold it come over here Dom grab this
other end we're gonna try to put it
behind the lever
let go
I'm taking this stuff we might need this
did you
grab dog
we'll grab this to get you up
all right get a halfway down and then
come grab this
when you jump off grab it
did he get it
grab it grab it grab it
uh pull them up pull them up
okay I'm gonna let go so I can grab his
side and pick it up
so he's still fell off
all right you got this you got this guy
you got it
let go you're too far up
now what's going on
oh we have to climb to the top don't we
hold up
maybe we can hit it with this everyone
get on uh I need someone else to get
over here
we gotta have some Force go
it's breaking ready go
foreign
just hold it with one hand
go
see you gotta listen to attic more often
I have a feeling moment we picked this
up It's Gonna Roll back yeah
[Laughter]
it was just a slow motion for me
okay hold up let me pick you up and then
you
all right now you try to pick me uh jump
on me
not trying to let go of one arm and
swing with the other
that's not working
maybe we can get on it through
this
I think we can it's just really unstable
all right I got you
foreign
what's up guys
we gotta get this box over there somehow
oh we got to raise that
okay let's try it
see if you can push this off
oh my God
is it stuck
okay hold up let's try this again
I think I'm gonna have to get on one
side
see if I can get on like the Rope part
no
oh I'm getting up there
what are we doing up here
hmm
oh
I was up there and everything man
probably after this mission called a
called a stream
oh someone joined
yeah someone did throwing
your socks
would be someone named rock your socks
joins
all right
all right so I think we can get this
over there
we just got to be careful
oh go go go go go go go go go
all right
I'm in the Next Room
I'm back on the blue pipe
laughs
we both fell off at the same time
we can get on this pipe
I've gotten on it multiple times
I bet you we get to the end of the world
if we stay on this pipe
okay hold up
he's got a pumpkin on his head
what is he doing
foreign
come on go in
man they keep doing it don't they
that's the end of the map right here
oh that's fine
here we go
I'm gonna end it
I'm gonna end it all for us
oh
probably ended here been streaming for
three hours
ow
and it's popped a muscle well
I don't think you can pop a muscle but
I appreciate it for coming through
appreciate the people in the chat coming
through that was it was fun
let me